- And work with your wife on
"It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia".
So how is that?
Is that good to work?
- I mean,
I feel a certain amount of pressure that
what if we're in the writer's room
and no story lines have
popped up for her character.
I'm like, I can't go
home and tell her this.
- Yeah, she'd be like, "What's up?"
- But it's also a blast,
although she's very mean
to me on the show.
- So she can get out any
frustration she might have
at home on camera.
- She seems to really enjoy it.
(Kelly laughs)
Really enjoy it.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- I think that's also healthy, you know?
She gets to act out her frustrations.
- Yeah, I like it.
So wait, so did did she play your sister
at some point in something?
- [Charlie Day] Yes.
- [Kelly] And was that awkward?
(audience laughs)
- Well, we auditioned together
for an episode of "Reno 911",
and they used to do improv auditions
and so Mary Liz and I
went into the audition
and told them that we
were brother and sister
and then we started
making out in the audition
and they were like, ""Oh my
God, we have to cast them."
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- They like used the storyline?
(audience clapping)
- Yeah.
- That's amazing.
Oh my, that could have gone either way.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- [Kelly] It was a gamble.
- Could have called a
service (indistinct) us.
- Oh my gosh, get them out.